hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast please make sure you
subscribe that way you get the episodes
as they come out welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r u garbage it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
we found out they grew up to be classy
or they're just a big old piece of [ __ ]
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful spring afternoon i'm down
here at aunt tony's basement
she's gone for the weekend where's she
at where do you think
ac what's she doing ac she's down there
at playing the tables probably
shaking him up hopped on the bus she
somehow got to casino bus to pick her up
in front of the house she's flexing on
all the other people i don't know how
she does it yeah
um my co-host is coming at you
from across the table this is a family
episode
just me and the old kipperino he's the
ceo of ru garbage he writes the checks
he breaks the next
give it up for my best pal kevin
james ryan hey thanks for tuning in
everybody happy to [ __ ] be here just
got some good news that i
want to get into what's that what
happened wait a minute let me see what
could it be
uh that we're doing the the big weigh-in
for
for my patreon weight loss run that's
one thing
for the listeners uh first of all let's
get a little a little bit of business if
uh please make sure you subscribe on
itunes why wouldn't you full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are
roof that ruth's burning
oh i mean we're going to get we're out
there we're going to get a polish roofer
in here
take care of it i don't know they tend
to be ruthless
i don't know okay uh
and then on the patreon guys you sign up
for the patreon.com you get bonus
episodes of ayg you get uh
episodes of hard feelings which is mean
a big man chopping it up [ __ ] runaway
hit baby that's
we have more ten dollar members than
five dollar members
i like it that's [ __ ] that says
something about the content on that over
patreon you're like [ __ ] frank purdue
you create a value in the marketplace
yeah okay you give them quality product
at an affordable price
yeah and they come running who's frank
purdue frank what
what are you a bozo frank perdue chicken
purdue chicken i didn't i don't know the
man personally
so that's that's a top-notch chicken
outfit you used to do the commercials in
the 80s unless that was an actor
and
yeah i know jim he looks like a chicken
i'm old school frank
and they use iodine over everything
that's how we did it in the 80s
uh yeah you can sign up for and then we
do a live stream every month
uh with our top tier patrons it's a good
[ __ ] time and then
this just in the the gauntlet was thrown
down
on an episode of hard feelings we're
doing an h foley weight loss challenge
over there on a patreon that's right i'm
about to lift 500 bucks off these two
losers
the deal is easy and clean it's all
gonna be covered on the patreon we're
gonna do
weigh-ins and everything we're doing
that right after this so i'm gonna have
to frisk you to make sure you don't have
any [ __ ] dumbbells in your cargo
pants or anything
[ __ ] people [ __ ] loaded playing
with loaded dice over
here two cats jump out of my shirt
[Laughter]
um i think that do we settle on you'll
get i got 100 bucks
28 pounds 28 30 28 pounds and 30 day
challenge
that's how we're doing we're going
old-school radio in here we said
20 and foley was like no way too easy
first of all i said i said 20 at a
thousand bucks and he goes no way
28 500 okay whatever and let me tell you
something i've come to a conclusion i
haven't figured it out yet it's like
taking broccoli off a fat guy but i'm
gonna
connect why would a fat guy have
broccoli yeah candy
um whatever listen what wait is that
what the saying comes from
like taking candy from a baby it's easy
it's also easy to take broccoli from you
you're giving it up but the baby wants
the candy the fat guy wouldn't want the
broccoli
anyway that's either here normally
you're eating here today whatever i'm
taking five hundo from you
bottom line wait i'm not giving up any
money we already said that
i don't have to give up anything i don't
lose 500 i can only gain
500. yeah i also look at it beneficially
like i can lose 28 pounds
um listen i'm gonna and that's what i
was about to say is
i'm splitting the money with one of the
fans
oh we're taking this radio dj yes we can
hold it now we gotta
i haven't figured out how but someone's
gonna be sitting
there i gotta be a patreon someone's
gonna be sitting on 250
dollars damn that's [ __ ] that was i
mean he's going rogue yep
and he's fully out of marketing over
here and if he if he makes it through
the month and he does it double or
nothing
the next month yeah i think that's what
we're doing maybe not double
no we're doing 500 500 from you dude
yeah but for another 28 pounds i'm gonna
own this dump in a couple of weeks yeah
i'll be making some changes to the
programming
you know okay
yeah you better start with you you can't
even show up on time
be cutting some dead weight around here
first thing i do is fire myself
yes just looking in the mirror sorry big
man i gotta do it hey
dummy you're coming up the works over
here i can only
i gotta go to the board i can only argue
so much so much one man can do
so that's what we got going on that's
gonna be i'm very excited i'm very
excited i want you to turn over a
[ __ ] new leaf
i'm doing the same thing i've been
running every [ __ ] day this week i'm
[ __ ] trying to eat right laying off
the booze i'm [ __ ]
feeling good i got chipping putt
tomorrow at 11.
me and cat i mean a new salsa event
you show up with your own bag of
tostitos where's where's the dip at
uh so i've been doing that i did that
last friday i'm doing that tomorrow but
now after the weigh-in
i don't get 20 pounds i don't get 28
pounds off in a month but once a month
i can't wait to see the look on your
two-face when you're handling i would be
ecstatic good
i'm going to be getting ready to be
excited go buy your sparklers now
listen if you lose 28 pounds that just
means this [ __ ] show goes on for
another 18 months okay
i'm investing in my own future here save
you a couple of bucks on lipitor every
month
it's kids paying my medical bills yeah
so you have that
and then we have the other the other big
announcements i just i just got the
[ __ ] text
as t-bone presses record i get a text yo
this is great third show in chicago
three
sold the [ __ ] out sold them out thanks
out to [ __ ] chicago
thank you we [ __ ] on you a lot chicago
but we love you oh man
three [ __ ] sold out shows so by the
time you hear this that fourth show
fourth and final i looked at the
schedule there ain't no other
[ __ ] show we can do it who are you
celine dion unless we start doing
nooners okay which i ain't doing
i ain't [ __ ] doing a brunch show okay
jerk offs i will
uh so the fourth show will be tuesday i
believe the 23rd or 20th
i don't know who's wait they're adding
it or that's it i just got the word it's
jesus i talked to the guys on the coast
too they said have at it if you can do
four to four oh
shout out to them if we don't sell it
out i'm pulling the plug by the way i
ain't doing three sold out and one happy
all right i'm pulling the [ __ ]
i'm calling a bomb threat one's friends
and family
one's a tune-up game come on come grab
tickets chicago thank you so much
chicago also the same week of chicago
there's going to be a [ __ ] we're going
to be in indy so it's going to go
chicago two shows
drive to indy do indy indy come the [ __ ]
out yeah let's go
[ __ ] chicago
uh and then two more in chicago thank
you so [ __ ] much and atlantic city
second show out of there get those
[ __ ] tickets june 18th
now we appreciate it we love you to
business well that was the business to
the real business
well you know garbagio what's this does
forgetting our producer extraordinaire
he's a good kid kippy he's a good kid
he's the magic man he's my comedy buddy
we go around we do
[ __ ] spots together listen to this
listen to listen to tapes and bits and
work on jokes
you've never recorded a set ever in the
history of your comedy career
my voice t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
everybody what's up dudes
we had a nice face time last night
though didn't we this [ __ ] idiot
what are you yelling at that was a fun
funny thing for you
this bozo yeah facetimes me and
and kippy kippy doesn't pick up because
he's a smart guy
no i was sleeping i was up at five
o'clock yesterday i was [ __ ] out
sleeping
yeah it was up to five o'clock look at
you like a farmer that was like 11
o'clock
yeah i just said it was up at five
o'clock and i i you take
two naps a day i gotta i gotta figure
out my phone calls with you
because if it's 11 to 12 30 he's out
three to five out and he knows it that's
why he's laughing he knows it
i answered the phone and follow by the
facetime pops up first of all his
camera's not on somehow he facetimed me
without activating his camera
i go hello and he goes what's this like
a 90 year old woman he goes
is this a facetime and i was like you
called me he goes no i didn't the
phone's in my hand
he pocket dialed us from his hand oh i
know oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i got to see the key cat
dogs say hi to kitty cat toby's little
cake
don't don't talk like that little stank
shout out is there any is there any is
it garbage to take naps
is that trashy yeah man you should
accomplish this
listen i work
way i do more way more stuff than you
and i don't take naps
i don't feel i don't feel like oh i've
worked enough today that i can take a
nap
really yeah yeah yeah no way gotta stay
fresh though
you're not you're as stale as they get
dude
as stan make croutons out of this guy
[ __ ] jesus christ
throw you in a microwave for a couple of
seconds loosen you up a bit
ew did you do that what that's tough
look any
any bread product in the microwave my
mom you should try pivots real quick my
mommy's
patreon.com for the weight loss
challenge i'm going to be [ __ ]
tightening the screws on this fat
bastard
i'm going to be over there with a
whistle get up fatty
one nap a day ending and please only
positive encouragement
yes honestly no negative i want negative
i'll take it
through i've done it i'll take care of
that that's good i want to hear you
can't do it you'll never make it you're
a loser
also hold on pimp pin for a sec i want
to shout out to our fans
a lot of podcasts get all negative love
radio shows to get a lot of negative
everybody [ __ ] on you guys the our
listeners are the nicest the best
the most supportive the nicest we love
you on youtube itunes wherever it is
you're [ __ ] fantastic i love you this
water's ice cold by the way
i feel like i'm testifying i love it
this thing's great
don't be loading up on water weight
either all right one bottle per hour
you're going to come back to you're
going to come back you jumped out of a
place anyway as we were discussing my
mom used to try to get away with [ __ ]
pulling frozen hot dog buns out of the
freezer
and throwing them in the microwave for a
couple of seconds while the dogs are on
the grill
yeah no bueno yeah yeah yeah hit the
[ __ ] brick
yeah keep it moving honey yeah denise da
nieces nieces known for that too a
little bit
and i tell you how these broads get
older they leave stuff in the freezer
that's from like
when i used to live there i come back
i'm like you still got this loaf of
bread
what the [ __ ] we doing it's beef steak
it's [ __ ] 2.99 get it out of here
yo i got a little ayg question for the
two of you bozos
do you perfect place to say t-bone
please go right ahead our door is always
open
best customer service and the best what
can i do for you today young man
do you currently have a bread box
what am i a which no i have a [ __ ]
bread box yeah no
um that was t-bone was it yeah
that was me texting t-bone
talk about a production school broadcast
in here
uh breadbox no um no we don't have one
we don't keep bread in the house i
i don't do bread my wife is gluten free
so we don't keep bread in the house
she's a real stick in the mud when it
comes to
when it comes to gluten when it comes to
snacks and stuff
no snacks maybe some cabbage she's
calling ice on her get her
some peanuts if i'm lucky
which is good because i'm an animal
somebody trying to make him
you're trying to make bread out of
peanuts
ever have gluten-free pasta it's like
eating shoelaces
they do pretty good now because they can
get like the rice ones or whatever i
don't know what's it called uh quinoa
pasta ain't too shabby
quinoa not bad got a little bite to it
you gotta cook it up
we do the zoodles zucchini zoodles
what they're called i think sounds like
something i did in college
once i did it once is that your roommate
zoodles
get over here you got them in a headlock
giving them noogies
you come back all tuned up from a brat
party he's doing his [ __ ]
trigonometry homework zoodles
no bread boxes yeah but i respect them
they were old school
they had a classy you don't have one now
do you oh yeah why would you
what's this whatever did it come with
the apartment you guys went out and
bought a bread box
no i ordered it on amazon where am i
gonna keep my bread in the cabinet like
a [ __ ] scumbag
put it on top of the fridge like a
gentleman this guy i got a kitty cat
he's gonna [ __ ] get in there
i'll give you that i'll give you that
yeah little stank always going for the
whatever
and foley's house it's just him and his
cat ripping a bag
i hide in the amazon boxes uh deserve
better
yeah all right let's [ __ ] [ __ ] let's
shift gears let's see it's okay it's a
[ __ ] family episode so as you know
we um we go we ask your questions on
patreon when you sign up for patreon
we'll answer your garbage questions
either with me being a big man or
meeting a guest us and a guest
uh i big man doesn't like me saying this
but there is a [ __ ]
backlog the fish are jumping on the boat
so we're working through them
give us some [ __ ] time we're getting
to everybody uh but this comment came in
on youtube which is
i knew you wanted to comment the comment
on youtube which
we get like oh my dad did this my uncle
did this and i'm always like yeah me too
you can relate
whatever or you know some of them are
wacky this one
this one's something this was a first in
a hundred and summit in episodes we've
had i've read every i
read and respond to almost every comment
this one was
this is from a guy named duke i don't
think he is a duke
but uh he goes hold us duke
can duke be a first name or that's
always a nickname nobody's named duke
dude once you hear what his parents do
it might
duke's not short for nothing right
surprise his name's not newcombe
get over here um all right he goes my
folks
have a customized van with a giant net
on the back that they use to hunt
bigfoot which is a term which is really
them just driving around a mountain
getting drunk on keystone light and
fireball
now could you imagine if your parents
actually hunted bigfoot to the point
where they had a modified vehicle
that they drove around
plus they're driving around hammered
they get pulled over they can toss that
cop in the net
better luck next year copper i don't get
it listen hunting
bigfoot's trash now my aunt and uncle
they hunt the abominable snowman which
is class
they're scientific people yeah yeah they
got skis and everything
yeah wait they're not some [ __ ]
hillbillies driving around the foot of a
mountain
wait a minute i don't know i'm caught up
in the the technicals of the trap itself
why does putting a net on the back of
the van
how do you what do you lure bigfoot in
the van with maybe it shoots the net
beef jerky or something
what is that that commercial
[Laughter]
johnny trailer piss off sasquatch yeah
yeah yeah i don't get that
no they bring him in with a fireball
squatch likes to party dude
he's just got a six or they're shaking
hey she'll do the both of us all right
he gets it but i mean if your parents
are earnestly if you come from people
who are earnestly
hunting bigfoot you're doomed your
bandits are doing it drunk they're
pretty unprofessional
or very professional it depends how you
look at it yeah
ah it's tough that's a [ __ ] tough
look
i just wanted to shout that was a mind
blower more and more
they're starting to say that there's a
really good possibility that there is
something out there especially in the
pacific northwest
that there could be a creature known as
bigfoot
it's just you lost on a camping trip i
don't know whatever
no no it's full he's taking his second
nap of the day send that to the writer's
room
the boys punch that up a little bit um
all right let's switch gears let's get
into some of the patreon
questions please and a couple of home
runs this one from joshua
ever been on america's funniest home
videos
[Laughter]
come on that's a dude remember watch it
america's funniest videos home videos
shout out to sagitt
that guy could host the [ __ ] program
by the way everybody was staying up on
something
oh man watching that no matter what we
were doing in the foley household
when it [ __ ] hit eight o'clock we
were running to the tv helped him dude
nothing's funnier than like the guy the
the neighbor getting hit and then nuts
with a rake or whatever yeah
you show me an american dad that doesn't
appreciate someone taking one of the
nards
and i'll show you a soviet spy all right
that's good clean american
nothing better yeah that was a [ __ ]
great program did you ever know anybody
on it
i remember they would like send it in
i'd be like mom can we send it in and
i'm like we don't even have a [ __ ]
video camera i felt like
even in the 90s the tapes were 20 years
old
well yeah they were i mean you know yeah
and i feel like when i watch it now
the tapes are from the 90s there's not
really cell phone footage on there
you're watching it now where are you
watching i've skipped
i've skimmed through it a couple of
times i've caught it on tv
have you ever heard of youtube it's not
it's not sagging it's the other guy tom
bergeron
that guy's like [ __ ] dude talk about
vanilla pudding
man that guy stinks like now it's
carlton though
it is carlton who i mean carlton stinks
too i'll be the first one to say that
the fact that pick a hike he's no
sagging
the fact that we're referring to him is
[ __ ] carlton yeah
tells you everything you need to know
haven't you made enough money beat it bo
zoe you're gumming up the works
do your little dance at home in front of
your kids or something wait i i have a
question
how many pornos do you think were
accidentally submitted
to america's sweating videos man the guy
doing the production team on that was
[ __ ] you probably had a stash going on
taking each home with me hey these are
no good
[Laughter]
tracking on them is all bad um
now there's there's two levels to
getting on
funniest home videos they're sending a
tape but never and
i don't know where they got the families
that actually showed up
remember they'd have like the coopers
sitting over there the mom was always
wearing like a mormon dress and she had
like
she was always like very light flowing
like layered kind yeah
a tight neck on it dude is that under
any sort of
thing should we churn in butter or
something probably something nice
underneath there though
is that old school does that old school
like hosiery turn you on
what do you mean you know if they like
lift it's like the girdle with the
it's like thick it's like cotton but
cotton that's like
yeah not like not like the sex do i like
fishnets and and the schnitzel you got a
pee pee of course you like fishnets with
the [ __ ]
i'm just saying that old school not to
not too much like 70s 80s
like the pointy cups or something those
things
[ __ ] around take the [ __ ] belt
sound they're
belt sander around them things couldn't
even make madonna look hot in that movie
right killing me over here [ __ ] try
pretty hard but not to make madonna look
like a [ __ ] three
kid was a race car back then 90s madonna
good night
oh man she was sick with my little
stinger
can we watch a league of their own again
you want to watch the phillies nope this
kid just won't stop watching like a
prayer i don't know what it is
kid likes the song um
that was a weird situation being on
[ __ ] uh
america's funniest home videos oh yeah
that squad they were like fake
yeah that's what i'm saying there's no
way we didn't have a tape record
and i was also being like how what
wackos are just
filming this stuff all the time no thank
you
[ __ ] goober families the video
recorder
came around once every in a great while
the dad that had that always had his
shirt tucked in
like he had his like you know he had
like a dress shirt like a
and he was usually up to something he
was caught doing something years ago
zooming in some
zooming in on something yeah never
trusted a dad with a [ __ ] camcorder i
remember an
uncle showed up one time to like a
thanksgiving
dude dude my family acted like the mot
like the [ __ ]
like we were the mob and the news just
walked in oh
get the [ __ ] out of here what the [ __ ]
you no pictures no pictures
hey jad your hoover [ __ ] yeah they
were like no [ __ ] thank you
he was [ __ ] dude now performance he
was labeled as a snitch in the 90s
real quick [ __ ] shout out
i found him in the trunk of a car in
front of yeah
i remember i remember like we all walked
outside and we were like what the [ __ ]
his deal in there [ __ ]
say say something for the camera hit the
bridge
hey you see these rocks [ __ ] kick
them
a performance is different that's when
the video camera got broken out if
somebody was doing
that you guys you were a video camera
family i mean i really wasn't but my
cousins were like i can remember like
you know my cousin's doing some things
and like you know her dad would like
would
would film it you know big guy huh the
channel six guy
the one on the yeah it was like
something like that but we never really
broke it out around the house while we
were getting all boozed up and [ __ ]
you know get out of here yeah it's a
goddamn christening for christ's sake
start punching your dad
yeah i gotta go to work i don't get that
[ __ ] i feel like the foleys were still
using shoulder-mounted vhs in the dvd
era yeah they probably if i if i
guarantee if your mom
probably wouldn't even use her cell
phone she would dust off
some [ __ ] now some old rca type thing
she ain't filming
[ __ ] she'll take a she'll take a picture
if she saw the camera or she do her
phone
huh is she like a phone or she got she
busted out like a disposable camera but
now
we ain't winding that thing up she one
of those old school ones throws the hood
over
now she uses no she first of all she
doesn't take pictures
she doesn't know how to do witnesses she
doesn't know how to use this this iphone
she has
she doesn't know how to use it to such a
degree it's amazing she knows how to
answer it i swear to god
yeah but for a while right before
cell phones with cameras started taking
off yeah she had the little
little square john that everybody had
zoomed out and
you never looked at the pictures no did
you ever have a uncle or something
go plug the vhs camera straight into the
tv to try and show the video
and then it's just like four minutes of
footage of him like accidentally filming
himself being like how the [ __ ] just
didn't work
yeah yeah yeah no editing uh-huh just
you're
watching the dailies [ __ ] yes yeah yeah
it's all [ __ ] shaky and [ __ ] yeah
this'll be good after a little color
correction yeah how about we do a first
pass on this okay
i'm not looking for the final cup but at
least of something
yeah it's trash man what a great great
question man america's funniest videos
garbage hey gang quick word from our new
sponsor
hellofresh with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured and mouth-watering recipes
delivered right to your door baby skip
the grocery store all together
and count on hellofresh to make home
cooking easy fun
and affordable big man that's why it's
america's number one win
meal kit you don't got to sell me on it
baby they weren't they got me hook line
and sinker not number two not number
three number four number five number one
hello fresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trips
um so you can get to cooking and enjoy
it get dinner on the table in about 30
minutes or less
try meals ready in 20 minutes or less
lightening prep recipes and quick
breakfast lunches
and snacks perfect for your busy
schedule they sent me and the big man
each a big box of stuff
big man what do you got i was a little
skeptical at first
yeah i go downstairs there's this box
down there i bring it up
everything's packed to perfection ice
cold
we they sent shrimp they sent pork they
sent chicken
so first order of business that night uh
my girl whips up
uh cajun shrimp all right over top of
kale
with crispy sweet potatoes and like this
like yogurt sauce on top i'm listening
it's unbelievable you got the
low-calorie
option it's fantastic yeah pretty good
guys great product go to hellofresh.com
garbage12 and use our promo code
garbage12 to get
12 free meals including free shipping
it's really worth it especially if
you're like honestly if you're on the go
if you're by yourself dude it she had it
ready in 20 minutes
it was fresh it's a lot of food too you
get a lot of food dude
they don't skimp yeah so we got two
meals out of it one more time
get the hell go to hellofresh.com
garbage12 and use our promo code garbage
12
for 12 free meals baby that's what we're
doing
check it out gang after years of fine
print contract and getting ripped off by
those big
wireless providers bozos if we've
learned anything
it's that there's always a catch am i
right kippy they get you coming and
going
they get you coming in so when the gang
over here first heard about mint
mobile's offer
for premium wireless service starting at
15 bucks a month we were like eh
there's got to be something behind it
here it is nope there
ain't it's all legit there isn't a catch
when it comes to mint mobile
mint mobile secret sauce is that they're
the first company to sell wireless
service
online by cutting out retail stores
there's no crazy overhead
there's no crazy cost and anything that
they save is being passed on
down to you oh baby straight to the
consumer oh yeah
honestly uh my wife has been using uh
mint mobile for like two or three years
now tommy uh when she was traveling here
from from europe we needed a cell phone
for and we didn't want to
get you know the big contracts or
anything you don't get locked in things
might not work out yeah they handcuff
you for like two three years so we got
mint mobile and she's just kept renewing
it and it's perfect 15 bucks a month
crazy all the internet you need calls
text whatever you need
it's easy peasy for people looking for
extra savings mint mobiles offers
premium wireless that's just 15 bucks a
month it'd be stupid to pass it up and
if you're not 100
satisfied with mint mobile they have you
covered with their seven-day
money-back guarantee you don't like it
don't matter get your money back good
night you know what i mean big man and
even if it's 15 bucks what do you know
what i mean i'm missing out on anything
no contract
no yeah use your same phone your same
phone number whatever you need it's easy
peasy
to make the switch uh to get your new
wireless plan for 50 for just 15 bucks a
month
and get the plan shipped straight to
your door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage one more time baby
mintmobile.com
garbage cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month with mint mobile.com
garbage do it gang we all shop online oh
yeah and we've seen the promo code
area yeah just sitting there and if you
ain't got one you feel like a real dork
yeah man i mean bozo central about to
pay full price like a
shucker yeah all right um but thanks to
honey
manually searching for coupons on the
internet is gonna be a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies
the best ones it finds to your court
all right honey supports over 30 000
stores online
they range from sites that have tech and
gaming products to popular
fashion products even food delivery yeah
they got it all baby
imagine you're shopping you know imagine
you're shopping for one of your favorite
sites
anywhere when you check out the honey
button drops down all you have to do is
click apply
coupons and they do all the work for you
crazy it's easy peasy no more
you know i feel like an idiot i go like
google and go like i used to go to like
google and go like
blah blah blah dot com promo code you
feel like an idiot then you get one it
doesn't work
honey does all that for you when we were
building the studio me and t-bone were
buying stuff on amazon like crazy
just using we were online finding this
finding that
threw it through the honey thing talk
about wetting our beaks
saving a couple of bucks ain't nothing
wrong with it i'm telling you
it's free money check it out i think
we're the lights i think we got a
discount on
uh some of the tchotchkes in the back we
got discounts on
i forgot about the tripods um honey has
over 17 million members
and that have saved over two billion
dollars
billion would have been serious yeah so
if you don't already have kardashian
money
if you don't already have honey you're
missing out that's the end of it it's
literally free installs in a few seconds
onto your browser
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast
yes if you get it you support us if you
like us you don't want to join a patreon
you don't want to do this buy a t-shirt
or whatever
you can support us easy-peasy just by
shopping there you go you know what i
mean
i never recommend something i don't use
my wife is huge on it get honey for free
at joinhoney.com garbage one more time
guys write it down
type it in joinhoney.com garbage now
back
to the show um all right let's see
this is from chris it just says soda
with breakfast question mark
which listen it's trashy it is
trashy soda is not a breakfast drink
disagree i do like it no it's trash
it's good i don't think so what do you
mean you don't think so
i would like it's not my argument please
because there's no fact that says
listen we do it but there's no factual
information that says
it's not part of a balanced breakfast
i'll tell you that much okay
allow me to sure respond there is no
difference between
a cup of coffee and a carbonated
cola beverage there sure is no there's
not yes
no there's not it's if you put cream and
sugar in your coffee
that's the same as having a soda which i
do not condone
despite my size but a diet coke
with an omelette nothing wrong with it
that's just as good
as having a cup of coffee also you
shouldn't
no because you're a bite and sip so you
don't bite and sip with the coffee you
bite and sip with the soda i bite and
sip with coffee all the time with hot
coffee yeah
an omelette yeah i don't think so you're
saying no no i
do i've i've eaten 10 000 meals with you
i've never seen it
well first of all i don't get hot coffee
i'm not a [ __ ] nine-year-old woman i
get an ice coffee yeah so that's so that
that's that that conversation is mute
your that argument is muted so what's
the difference between having a nice
coffee and a diet soda
nothing i still bite and sip on both
sure i understand there is a difference
between a
bite and sip with a hot coffee though
you have to give me that caffeine
content
alone caffeine content alone i think
there's more in diet coke than there
isn't coffee
34 milligrams in diet coke 95 milligrams
in coffee jesus christ that's weird
because a diet coke usually hits me
harder
than regular coffee um [ __ ] whacks you
out
well you drink more of it than coffee
true you know what i mean you get a two
tree refills if they're crazy
but no it is you got free refills at the
at the airport on diet coke
i yeah remember that yeah i was stunned
by that um
well the first one was 9.50 so they
might as well
hit me over the head for three of them
uh no but a no place no commercials
for breakfast whenever it's an eggo
commercial a [ __ ]
english muffin commercial a [ __ ]
cereal commercial
the tray's coming in there's never a
glass of [ __ ] screaming cold dc on
there okay
milk juice anything like that
that's what it is okay coffee
milk juice that's a breakfast drink
santa
part of a balanced breakfast yeah you
don't [ __ ] out of you got orange mouth
and [ __ ]
it's trash and it is kind of
psychopathic behavior but i
like it yeah i like it too over the
pandemic when i was cooking every i was
cooking breakfast every morning
screaming i'd sit down with a [ __ ]
screaming cold coke zero
good nah talk about kicking things off
yeah dude
holy [ __ ] um but it's trash
okay i'm glad you rolled over on that
one appreciate that
that's what i do the old rollover
uh this one's just i don't even get this
is from geronimo
in case it's not been done already uh
ever use a fire engine to water your
lawn
what the [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] know what
are you fired what are you a firefighter
how the [ __ ] did you get that thing to
come out the water and how big's the
lawn
must had a busy weekend i don't get that
that's [ __ ] ever use a fire
i think we filled our pool one time with
it what
where'd you get it what did you mean i
got at the mall what do you mean where
do you think we got it the
i think the fire department at one point
was like in charge of it no
no that costs money because i call i
remember it cost money oh okay because
my mom always complains about how do you
fill yours
the sink our pool yeah the hose to take
15 years
takes a couple days yeah it does
that's a big pool too by the way huge
yeah but she always complains about that
at the beginning of the year because her
water bill
skyrockets when we fill the pool they
ain't doing that for free
no i remember i think i remember it was
like we had to pay for them to come out
and they turned like we used their hoes
and they hooked up to the [ __ ]
i think they hooked up to the hydrant
with that thing was built in like 15
seconds
i was waiting there with my swimmies on
you know
it was cold as ice dude
i remember that man it was like oh
that shit's coming from middle earth
there's a polar bear [ __ ]
he's doing backflips man you let that
water run
one long enough in the summertime the
chickens aren't taking yeah it's kind of
i think
yeah [ __ ] hooked up to poland spring
or something i don't know what's up
that shit's great uh and then this is
also in the same vein this is a tag on
question which we've talked about
our pool's real cold for the first
couple of weeks anyway
because our pool she only has to fill up
like three quarters or
she only has to fill up like what's the
rain do the rest
she'll go for rain next week she only
fills up like a quarter of the pool
because
the pool stays filled through the whole
year
we don't empty we don't drain our pool
it's just as a cover on it and has
chemicals in it
so it doesn't freeze yeah so she just
adds a little bit more water shocks it
throws the chlorine in there
cleans it all out or whatever it is and
then we go so that water at the bottom
of that
has been in there that's what they use
for the vaccine
go get some gunk from the folies no it's
been in there all winter
and you can tell winter water dude did
you but did you see my hand just do that
that was
that was i literally got the [ __ ]
hebrew dude
it's ice cold it's like [ __ ] cryo
[ __ ]
treatment find the lakers in there
[ __ ] his head's floating there ice
cold they ever tell you this story me
and my buddy
me and shout out to my boy pat we got
drunk in college
and at home like it had like in the
summer one night and we were going back
to his we were at a house party and we
like walked through the woods
and we got stuck and it was like five in
the morning four in the morning we got
stuck in a thing of sticker bushes
like to the point dude he fell and i'm
like dude we were just
you were just getting caught like it
looked like look we got attacked by
[ __ ] werewolves
and we're bleeding all over the place
and i'm go we get to the point where
we're like it got
slightly getting worse and worse then we
were just stuck where we couldn't move
or you couldn't stop because you would
just be [ __ ] hemmed up so you had to
keep [ __ ] pushing through
and he fell man and he's go i'm like
i'll pull you up because don't eat it so
i pulled him
he's got he's so [ __ ] up he's going
just leave me man just [ __ ] save
yourself dude go get help
leave me i'm like i'm not gonna do it
how do we finally
we get out of it dude and we get he's
like we get back and we're like we hug
when we get out we're crying we're in
tears you're just
a real tough guy dude we're just in pain
it looks like we fought like dude it's
just
slices everywhere and now we're starting
to swell up and stuff because it's like
so much trauma to the skin
just because it's like we have thousands
of [ __ ] cuts all over us
so we get back to his pool like i just
want to jump in the pool and clean
everything out
we don't know his dad shocked the pool
before he went to bed
dude i [ __ ] swan dove in and we
immediately both come up
in tears dude his dad woke up from
us yeah screaming crying in the backyard
he said what the [ __ ] you idiots doing
there's two grown men [ __ ] laying
back there bloody and crying
he's like what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh
man my dude that was a story my mom said
what the [ __ ] happened to your arms and
legs i'm like
to tell her i got stuck in the woods as
a grown man
is a tough look you lost me at picker
bush
[ __ ] [ __ ] say what back in the day
a couple of thorn bushes they get you
i get it that's the definition of hemmed
up
man going through trails woods trails
when you were a kid if somebody was
ahead of you
and they would catch a branch of pickies
and then it would swing back and just
yeah oh my god i felt like you were
fortunately amazon oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah brutal this one's from
dylan to tag on to your pool because
you're an above ground pool kind of
family
yes we are um above ground pools and
microwave hunts and we've talked about
this ever make a whirlpool in an above
ground pool which is the highest benefit
of the above ground pool is the world
would you like to know something what
mine's so big it can't i was thinking
that when i read that question
anna you have an oval too you're not a
straight circle
it's gotta be tough for you to get
momentum going but the one we had in
wilkes-barre you could
and let me tell you something that we
got that thing cooking [ __ ] drowned
the cracking in that thing
yeah thing was hot it's like an at-home
lazy river
how do you do it you just get a couple
of boys couple of buddies
couple of homies and you swim in the
same direction
for like a couple of minutes and that
gets all the water
just swirling around and if like you get
it moving quick enough with a
if you had a couple of older kids they
can really get it oh yeah
throw it afloat or two and then and then
have some you literally like can't swim
the opposite way you're just like kind
of swimming in place and then grab an
older cousin on the [ __ ]
uh on like the the the floaty just start
building this
then you got some waves going yeah now
you got the perfect storm you're playing
george clooney yeah it's like
it's like getting caught in the inlet
you're getting it from every angle yeah
it's great and undertow
there is nothing good about an above
ground pool i i'm
crazy i bet get yourself in a whirlpool
as a seven-year-old
that's a good [ __ ] time that is a
good [ __ ] time yeah
and i am an anti i am anti-aboveground
pool
but that's clean living in the
summertime as a kid nothing wrong i
wouldn't mind one right now to be honest
with you a couple of [ __ ] butt
heavies
cruising around throw the fills on let's
do it
yeah um all right this one's from
comment deleted
are there any windows in your house
propped up with a household item
like it just falls and you have to prop
it open not at my parents now
not not don't act like they're like the
[ __ ] the keystone of [ __ ] they got
the windows
they have windows last time i was there
you were missing a wall they were in the
middle of construction
it's all really it's all done now it's
all nice looks great
yeah fantastic oh i'm glad that the
drywall's not exposed anymore it looks
great
no it still is put a little knickknacks
on the inside
kind of metal studs hide weed in there
it's nice um
no nothing like that my apartment that i
lived in with my boy
uh i was living in yeah here's a no in
new york in
my first when i moved up here that
window was broken forever and we used to
smoke inside
and you just have to prop it open with a
plastic snapple bottle
and that snapple bottle stayed there for
i'm talking
the five years i lived there that it was
the same snapple bottle
was it filled no it was empty was it
raspberry diet
it was you've definitely propped open
that window with that box i think it was
a raspberry caught a couple of bernies
back yeah
if you're propping a window no shot
there's a screen in it no you need to
put your hand out there to ash
like a gentleman smoking inside man
really hits different it's crazy
yeah you feel really good we have a
buddy that just bought an apartment in
new york
and i go over there late night to have a
couple of beers and we can smoke
bernie's in his apartment
it's crazy real nice this guy plays by
his own rules this guy's bonkers
it's crazy um all right this one's from
little homie know anyone with an eye
patch
an eyepatch says a lot about or you know
it leaves a lot open for interpretation
you catch a guy with an ipad i've had to
wear them periodically
pirates of the caribbean now scratching
my if i scratch my eye with my contacts
but nobody that wore one steadily now
really [ __ ] up your depth perception i
bought one one time as a kid and a rite
aid well you know why the pirates wore
them it wasn't because they were i was
[ __ ] up
they kept one eye covered so that when
they walked down into the
into the ship they get switched up and
they could see
so they could see quickly man you ever
get hemmed up in the bathroom in the
middle of the night when you turn the
lights on
feels like someone just threw a
flashbang in there
i can't see [ __ ] dude that's a [ __ ]
you flip the lights on too fast and
you're not ready
it's like putting your head in the vice
i once saw a guy
pull a glass eye out and throw it into a
cup during a game of beer pong
what and the people you [ __ ]
associate with
are grade a dirtballs yeah it was
[ __ ] nuts take his keys for the
weekend
oh man i don't want to do this t-bone
has the homies coming out and i was like
dude i cannot wait
how many how many people are coming 11.
11 homies got the got the news
and it was like we're gonna be there not
one hotel room among them
doubletree 11 homies and 15 duis
[Laughter]
i wouldn't ask any of them for any clean
piss i thought you said they were all
staying with you
like four or five of them probably oh
god
shower it's gonna smell like a bum's nut
sack in that place
um get the cat a hotel at least
stretch out a little bit these bozos
coming in
oh yeah he's going to be hiding yeah i
would be too
i don't i don't blame the guy i'd be in
the breadbox
[Music]
he texted me he's like yeah i got like
11 homies coming out and they're exactly
how full he pictures them
oh man i'd love to see the attire at
that funeral not one not one decent suit
among the bunch i bet
do you get a suit yet tomorrow
he's gonna have one-on-one i don't know
but i can see his
boys up in a tuxedo t-shirt i do have
there is one friend who is wearing like
pants from my boy kev and then his shirt
from my homie tim
it's bad news ugh that guy
man good dude couple of bazos
want to know what his name is bozo
hahaha
goober yams
dude yams is coming what's up bro
yeah you know why we call him yams one
night he kick flipped the yam it was
crazy
he shreds his guy it's more sweet
potatoes than everybody i know
i don't like him he stole my mom's
wedding ring but the kid can shrink
stole my mom's wife shout out to yams
dude yams is the only person i ever saw
do that like
do that like sitcom move of paying a
credit card bill with another credit
card
oh yeah yeah that's a bit i've done that
no i haven't i've wanted to
i never had the extra credit card dollar
credit
limit get out of here that's what you
got two i thought it was five
no you're five i'm two really hey you
thought you had two this whole time wow
that's
not in charge of your finances you are
you thought you had my credit limit
i knew one of us had bad credit i just
figured it was me
um shout out to the kia by the way
um
toby said it best time we got in the car
the other day and he goes this is a nice
car
if you've never had a nice car i was
like yeah exactly
because these are nice cars for people
who don't have never had a nice car
yeah the kia the kia name is tough
but they look pretty good you gotta
admit t-bone
the key is not i gotta i got the [ __ ]
i might as well have like a projector in
that thing i got a big flat screen on
that bad boy
i wouldn't call it big you ever been to
tesla
no it still looks russian that's the
only thing it looks like so do you
hello i open you up there's just little
foley's inside
that's gonna be his trick for the weight
loss challenge couldn't breathe in there
uh yeah it just looks like a kia
it looks like a car from like another
world
or like an alternate universe does
always come back to comic books with you
maybe um all right here let's get back
to the action
shoot it all right this one's from casey
ever no ever knows
they just say ever it's so funny that
this is their this is how they ask them
now
ever know someone to propose via the
megatron at a stadium
the jumbotron first of all getting on
the jumbotron
did they write megatron they said
megatron yeah i guess
i guess it is jumbotron that's so trashy
yeah it's definitely jumbotron yeah
do you ever know anybody married on a
transformer um
getting i remember as a kid at like a
flyers game
getting on the jumbotron was
the height of fame the height of success
if you could do something to get that on
you
oh what did you do i was [ __ ]
bragging the next day at lunch
i was recreating it i was like you get
over here so here's my dad
i'm [ __ ] anybody camping against the
capitals game last night
anybody see when the camera panned to
section 218
see a fat kid eating a pretzel if you
ever wind up on the jumbotron do
yourself a favor
look down the barrel of the camera don't
be the bozo looking up
yeah well you want to see yourself it's
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
be a professional well if you don't see
yourself on the jumbotron are you really
on the jumbotron you can catch yourself
later on the highlights
who knows you're going to make the
highlights you'll make the highlights no
no or the rebrand listen don't listen to
these two [ __ ] videos
people are doing this i want you to live
your best life
now stop it if you're ever at a game and
you get the chance to be on a [ __ ]
jumbotron
throw your peepers up to the megatron
and take a look at yourself and who's
this [ __ ] dirt ball kissing
everybody's girlfriend that's what i do
those are set up
are they yeah no no i got on a kiss cam
one time
yeah kiss cans aren't set up but when
they go for the kiss and she says no or
he says no then he turns over to the
other girl those are all set up
our buddy connor tried to get us to
write those
so this was maybe like four or five
years ago uh-huh he realized these
moments can go viral
that you can produce these jumbotron
moments that'll then go viral for like
the team okay they're just free
advertising for the team
so all they all started doing that so
our buddy started working for the sixers
we we were like we were writing sketches
for that or like he was like hey come up
with like 10 ideas
i don't remember this yeah and he was
like for and you guys will come down and
you'll be like the in-house jumbotron
actors i don't remember that at all yeah
and he was like yeah is there any money
changed hands on this
uh we took a retainer we did no no no no
no no
came home to the piece mom i just hit
the optimus prime time
i'll be on the megatron
transformers fat guys in disguise
where's my foam
i need a foam finger and a footlong hot
dog
no questions asked uh yeah so they so
that's those are all viral things of
like the dance challenges and stuff like
that where like
the nerdy white guy just all of a sudden
is the greatest dancer and whatever
they're all scripted i hate so they go
viral all that [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] game especially at
baseball games when i do that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
except for the fanatic when he's dancing
on a dugout that's clever i mean oh yeah
that's [ __ ]
that's top notch right there that big
belly floating around you can't [ __ ]
he's got like a gyro system in him or
something i can't buy that yeah nothing
like the fanatic
or i'll give you i think it's in
milwaukee when the hot dogs chase each
other around the stadium
or the freeze is pretty good what's the
freezer i don't know what the guy that's
super fast
yeah and he catches everybody yeah he
[ __ ] stops smoking
[ __ ] leaves those dudes high and dry
and he'd hunt my fat ass down
real quick give you a three-week head
start
you could be in the golf cart let me
start in the first inning oh man that's
[ __ ]
anything and i mean anything
remotely that revolves around the
jumbotron
whether it's uh in memoriam it doesn't
matter what it is
it's [ __ ] trash you know what i get
way too involved when they were like
asking your girl to to get married in
public
is [ __ ] garbage if more than if more
than you and your girlfriend are okay
ready
if more than you and her father or
whoever
family is i like it well i'm just saying
usually ask permission
did you yeah you did gentlemen i like
that now sometimes obviously
situations arise where you know the old
man's not in the picture
you know what i mean so you know you
don't you don't do that that's why i put
on the jumbotron so we can see it from
heaven
is his tv big enough so we can see this
so he can see it from jail way up there
so you can see it from the can is more
like it or whatever
[ __ ] uh trailer park he's living in
in north dakota
now if an engagement involves anybody
but
you and her it's trash now you can have
the family come
and have them like incognito you know
what i mean
okay but that's it when you're getting
too elaborate
like when you're involved in the cops
and [ __ ] like that remember that one
video yeah one where they like they
they cuffed the guy yeah get your hands
off of it yeah and he's like will you
marry me it's like yo you [ __ ] dork
first of all you're on a sock you're at
a shell gas tank i know what is all
hopped up on premium
man i see a lot of people that shouldn't
be getting married
why are you looking at me huh um
[ __ ] what was i gonna say also to i get
way too involved
at least as a kid i haven't been to a
game and obviously pandemic and
everything but
i remember being so [ __ ] hyped when
they would like ask i always want to be
the guy they asked to quite like the
trivia question to
wow you [ __ ] and they they wanted to
be like and not they would ask always
some [ __ ] bozo in the fifth row be
like
who was the whatever what where's like
they would do like the three card monty
with the pucks at the flyers game and
you had to follow
like the wb mason whatever logo
to win free tickets or something shout
out to wb mason those guys are all over
the place i don't know how they're in
business
i think they're trash they're
hemorrhaging [ __ ] money and
advertising
but we're talking about them toby bleep
up so they uh
and he'd be like they scream like it's
on the left and you're like yelling the
right answer and like he gets it wrong
god damn it you're all [ __ ] mad oh
you are a trashy sports fan
have you ever seen someone get booed at
a sports game
like a fan no like uh like
like a player like like every ever
involved in like a like a full bore
stadium wide boo yeah what
it's the best oh have you ever seen
sports before who is this guy
[ __ ] skater joe over here you kidding
me um yeah
philly's boo everybody yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh i forget you guys like
famous for that
oh yeah boo everybody also check out
wing boom ourselves if you're not
familiar
i've spotty spent a couple of months
there one night
dude the wing bowl do you know what the
wing bowl is
it's a racist chicken wing that's what
it was
you could slice it any way you want yeah
whatever you however you want to paint
it but it
is so the wing bowl is a thing uh
in local philadelphia legend i don't
know if they still do it anymore
your headphones unplugged or something
they keep coming undone yeah okay
um why are you looking at me you're the
one stepping on him i wasn't stepping on
him
i was just looking at the ball of knot
that it's wrapped up in
well you can fix it i'm i'm not a
production guy here
on their talent to my contract do you
need talent to be a talent oh
you hired me oh it's gonna reflect in
your
[ __ ] paycheck this month without a
laugh that was just
incredibly rude
[Laughter]
you got it double bagged on it
um yeah
yeah wing bowl is a wing-eating contest
in philadelphia that like there's months
leading up to it then they do it the
night before the super bowl or the
friday before the super bowl
and it's mayhem
like pride they do it at 6am so i
don't do it anymore first of all oh
whatever the one year i went we started
we went down at midnight and doors open
at 6 00 a.m
dude like my friends are doing acid
mushroom like it's [ __ ]
it's the biggest dirt ball every dirt
ball in the tri-state area comes out to
this thing
and i'm talking fights that dude's
eating dragon wings
dude i'm talking [ __ ] fist fights
booing throw and change it pete like
it's chaos it's
not don't they do the anthem though
before don't they play the national
league dude i'm talking
there would be there was fist fights and
the cops now the cops are in there
because those poor security guards and
the red
the red shirts ain't doing it they
they're it's k the cops are in there
and the cops are punching dude and
they're just spraying pepper spray
like in in section 112 just [ __ ]
dousing everybody
it's crazy but they followed up with a
little blue cheese sprout
i'm more of a ranch man myself you got
any celery over here
throw a couple of carrots over here we
it's a [ __ ] scene
anything involving anything like let's
get this clear is
[ __ ] garbage if you get more than 30
people together in philadelphia they're
throwing batteries
there's going to be a fight yeah there's
good yes for sure for
shh yeah the jumbotron man we used to do
that we used to do the mummers
we used to do the [ __ ] the wing bowl
we were like
we've done every parade like we were
we've ran into every time
when the phillies won the eagles one we
ran to the [ __ ] right we were like
real looking back i'm like parades are a
really tough look
backpack full of beers just like
spraying them and screaming
man if i could have my 20s back and
early 30s
parades are trash um all right this
one's a [ __ ]
hr home run yeah
uh this is for braxton do you
or does anyone in your family pronounce
the l in the word
tortilla or quesadilla or the j in
jalapeno
a jalapeno jalapeno tortilla chips
tortilla i
yeah there's uh for sure my family's too
big for this to not happen i'm sure i've
heard it
and there's like there's like probably
200 of us
there's definitely a couple uh
quesadillas tortillas
quesadilla tortella's for sure tortella
chips
for sure yeah get the tortilla chips man
hers restaurant style tortilla chips
good the knockoff brain
go tostito if you're buying anything
maybe some of the new ones
the tostitos ones are too thin though
the restaurant ones and they're [ __ ]
like the size of frisbee it's like a bat
we gotta break them apart
you can't even get it in whatever
reciprocal you're dipping it's like a
[ __ ] airplane wing
it's like a hang glider trying to get my
salsa on that's why you always go
scoops go with the scoops scoops you get
a nice big gutter you got to take care
of them though
you got to treat them like [ __ ] a
faberge egg because you
you got a bunch of broken scoops you're
dead in the water yeah you need those
things
solid they're unbelievable but then also
the scoops when you get to the bottom of
the bag with the scoops you got nothing
nothing with at least with the
restaurant style you get a half a chip a
quarter of a chip or you do a little tip
you can't be it's like a fingernail
you're trying to pick up you know you
know what's great is the
it's really trashy but finding a curled
up [ __ ] tortilla chip
those are awesome make your own taco
with those things you can hang pen and
one of them things dude that's like
riding the rip curl
really load up yeah they're [ __ ] up
the tortilla chip in 2021 we should have
a genetically engineered chip that it
comes out a certain way
and it should be and you think you're go
you're talking about genetic engineered
chips you think you're gonna lose 28
pounds in 30 days
once i get this solved
so i cracked this case you would need to
twirl
he has to take his lab coat off to put
his running shoes on
you would need to you need to twirl a
part of it
it should always be that so you have a
lip you're looking for something yeah
all right well because nine and a ten
chips stink
you get that one good one you know you
only get that one good one
nice fresh thing of salsa good night
man you don't stand you're crazy
you're crazy okay okay
and i'm splitting it with a fan that's i
forgot about that that's
nuts great what'd you think of that i
don't know
this is what i think you probably owe
someone 250 and you're gonna make
you're gonna make them win the contest
and the winner is my uncle steve the
winner is my brother
shout out to my brother everybody shout
out to con edison energy for winning the
250
splitting big fans over there kinda
yeah yeah shout out to bill matrix
everybody
tammy at spectrum cable you just won
dollars and i got my cable turned back
[Laughter]
splitting it what a thing um
this one's from joe millette mellet
mallet i don't know how trashy you are
that's it
l-l-e-t i like mullet joe mallette it's
good it's a good name
solid name joe millett new patreon
that's the guy you call
yeah yeah joe malette will take care of
you yeah
he's coming off the bench and he's going
right into the penalty box yeah
now he's scheduling something he's doing
something around the house he he's your
guy
insurance guy i was leaning insurance
well you should share like a pair of
dockers
we use joe millett that's who we use oh
your insurance guy yeah hey take out mom
in a nice 401k joe mallette
joe he sounds like a hockey player to me
i'll give you that a little bit
82 rangers joe mallette coming off the
bench come on he didn't even wear gloves
[Laughter]
no teeth didn't use a stick
uh this is from joey millett uh
new patreon member here yeah anybody in
your family ever owned a portable
handheld
tv yes my aunt kathy
was big on them really yeah i had one of
those
i'm talking one of the little sony ones
that like when you look at it now it
looked like an iphone
it was like a little sony one and it
worked it [ __ ] yeah they did work
it worked took it all the way to the
front porch
you got cable hooked up to the side of
it
[Laughter]
now she would have it for like church
and uh like
she'd be watching in church well she
can't miss her story skip
maybe not like actual proper mass but if
it was like somebody's like
christening or graduation and there was
like something big yeah
phil's were honest yeah yeah it feels
like the eagles are on or something like
that we had that
just to [ __ ] make sure we keep tabs
yeah that's it's for sporting events
it'd be weird if you were watching the
news on it or something you know what i
mean
yeah yeah just seeing what was going on
yeah um
we're gonna have to take those boogers
off your pants before we weigh you by
the way well you know what we're at the
way you're naked
too you know what's uh you know what's
or at least in europe
really trashy is there's been multiple
times where
a wedding or something coincided with a
huge
huge philadelphia and they rolled a tv
in like i mean like penn state ohio
state
or something like that and as soon as
you get to the reception all the guys
[ __ ]
right to the bar [ __ ] glued to the tv
all standing [ __ ] back
yeah trash trash thing but i get it uh
we had one my stepdad was the king of
having like
cutting ed technology 10 years too late
right so like he shows up
with like uh he showed up with a
with a handheld tv literally like iphone
like one of the ones like that
no those things were super trash the
cooler ones the lunchbox things
that's the bricks they were like oddly
long yeah
no way like the tube went really he had
one like a handheld and we'd like pull
it up like a walkie-talkie kind of yeah
that's what i'm talking about but he
would try to flex with it way too late
but yeah like like a year ago take it
out at a family party or something we're
like jesus christ yeah
it only takes 12 debates yeah exactly
who's got battered let me get him out of
the remote we're like dude there's crows
what are you doing
[ __ ] embarrassing me no they took the
weird ones what were the really really
big ones
the these are the nine volts for the
squares with the two little reciprocals
like the nine volts i'll give you
because they were you put them in in the
fire
alarm plus and you want to [ __ ] open
up a day lick one of them
they would find the stick on your tongue
that'll put it that'll put some pep in
your step
[ __ ] a blue chew get one of them bad
boys those things are great i remember
we discovered that you could do that if
i can get the little kids hey
come here i can put this yeah no
i'm talking about the big johns the d's
or the really big ones no is that what
they were these wait these are the big
circle cylinders
are kind of like a set of brass knuckles
kind of yeah what are the what are what
what are the
they're abcd no a's are the little guys
yeah you have that you have triple a's
but then it went to d i don't know what
c's were
i think c's are just a regular like like
once in the commercial like the duracell
back
they're double a's no no no the big
they're bigger ones they were for like
toys back in the day
the big bees is the one i'm talking
about those things
when you needed one of those good
[ __ ] luck you had to go to radio
shack and [ __ ]
three towns over nobody had those things
yeah
those huge ones i don't know this is all
wonky to me what is a d
battery then yeah it's a big battery was
just what i thought a c battery was
that's what i'm saying the ds are the
really big ones the ones that nobody
ever had you had like two of them in the
drawer that's it
and you always needed like seven of them
i don't know it was always because we
had a big track when i was a kid
no not these not these man pajamas
that'll that'll power the house no the
big boys right there two wolves yeah
there you go
yeah the d the c's look the same as that
no they're not they're smaller
okay [ __ ] pinhead i'm telling you six
times
because we had a big track when i was a
kid a what a big track
what's that you don't know what a big
track is it was a programmable
uh like space vehicle
it was a toy but you could program it
and it would
elon relax will ya it would go like four
feet turn right turn left again and then
it would like
empty it's it's dump truck would would
open big track
they were called and they took serious
back like
you needed like 40 d batteries to get
this thing going for half an hour sounds
like cutting
egg tech technology back in this was it
probably
this was probably christmas 1981. all
right well that brings this up this is
this is from nick and this was big in my
family
and it's a did you or any of your
cousins or if you're a parent do you do
this now
skip this step when putting stickers on
your kids hot wheels tracks
do you remember that we were the bells
and whistles never got assembled we were
my dad would put the make the thing
functional
then the stickers the lights the
trinkets
they all went by the wayside we were
real meat and potatoes when it came to
when it came to stuff putting models
together putting g.i joe things together
star wars things together stuff like
that stickers
were optional they never made it not to
mention
stickers were usually ripped into first
and those were getting slapped on
the dog or something yeah yeah yeah they
never made it on the hot wheels yeah
you know we were terrible i didn't have
the steady hand as a kid to do that
no way i got [ __ ] yeah i got peanut
butter all over my fingers and [ __ ]
looking parkinson's feet over here that
was no good
dude as a kid nothing worse than a
wrinkly sticker
sticker wrinkle can't get it out and my
dad was like i just did this for an hour
i ain't putting the [ __ ] stickers on
jerk off
[ __ ] have at it did you ever build
models when you were a kid
no no
no i remember somebody for like
christmas and uncle and cousin somebody
some schmuck that wasn't that close to
me gave me a [ __ ] hey somebody [ __ ] up
at the factory this thing ain't put
together
somebody somebody gave me like a paper
plane
book like how to make like proper sturdy
paper plane so i'm like and it came with
like
thick paper i'm like i'll give this a
shot for five
[ __ ] minutes meanwhile look who i
looked over at somebody i was like yo
rap get the [ __ ] gift receipt for
this thing
hey mom get the paperwork done this way
this thing's going the [ __ ] back
somebody find a [ __ ] hobby lobby
and drop me off on the way
because this thing ain't [ __ ] coming
in the house i know that much
dude hobby stores were a tough look it's
kind of a toy store you know
it was weird yeah the guy working the
front desk
whack talking about a [ __ ] chest of
the molester hit them
hit the bricks allied hobbies will you
i'm talking
bald guy with ponytails oh yeah yeah
yeah
glasses probably had a hog on them
though
oh dude because we because we were in
the planes and [ __ ] like that when we
were kids
and my brother especially buying two
seats
my brother got into [ __ ] models for a
little while
we're not talking victoria's secret
we're talking messerschmitt 109.
we're talking virgin 202's
that's so funny because i remember my
one my one buddy's dad
like a whole set up downstairs with like
it like he was it was like an architect
set up but it was just for models like
he had like the special light
and the tweezers and all that stuff oh
this is where your dad goes and not get
laid
but anyway they were tough man
but i was going to ask you their
stickers do you know how you put
stickers on models you had to put them
in water first
too much for me dude how the [ __ ] is an
eight-year-old supposed to [ __ ] do
that
our planes came out all gunked up with
glue and stuff
it never looked like anything remote on
the [ __ ]
i did get into rockets for like
a two three week period johnny rockets
hell of a milkshake uh no remember i
don't i don't know if that was 90s
it was 90s i don't know we weren't
[ __ ] with anything like that
those things were like you put them
that's a weapon engine well that's what
was
that's a projectile that was so that's i
didn't care that it was a rocket i go
i'm gonna [ __ ]
blast this thing the [ __ ] off let's go
the explosion part was cool to me i
didn't care
i didn't give a [ __ ] about rockets and i
remember
we did something in school you weren't
in it for the humanity no i was in it i
was like let's [ __ ] torch something
dude let's [ __ ]
let's hit a bird with this thing
ah it's [ __ ] up and we did a collab i
did like a course or a class or like
it was an after school thing maybe what
you [ __ ] nerd
when i got there and it was a bunch of
you know [ __ ]
rocket kids not me i was i was odd man
out a bunch of rocket kids
and they were like with the stickers and
the deca
i was like dude [ __ ] i'm going bare
bones give me the [ __ ] tube
give me the dazzle give me the engine
let's [ __ ] let's light the candle on
this puppy somebody draws skull and
bones on this thing
and grab the [ __ ] grab the grill
lighter will ya
dude i got a [ __ ] i got an orbit to
catch
somebody stuffed a frog inside and let's
do this thing oh all right let's wrap it
up
ah that's it oh man i was having a
[ __ ] good old time here
uh love the family apps love you so much
fun love everybody love the questions
thank you so much
we will be back next week kippy what do
you got for him uh you know
obviously you guys are the [ __ ] you
know you're the [ __ ] you know all the
plugs but itunes youtube
patreon and i'm at kevin ryan comedy on
all social media get us both to 10k i'm
like close to eight get us to ten so we
can get the [ __ ] swipe up stories
and i can get verified like a [ __ ]
gentleman yeah let's keep growing we
love you guys very much we'll see at the
live shows
uh again added a second show in atlantic
city june 18th make sure you come and
see that if you live in indianapolis
get some [ __ ] ticks come out and see
the squad the live show is fantastic
you've seen the national clip
we're going to have a good time we'll
see you there we love you peace